yeah welcome sorry to put into this
video FM cool layer corner yeah that's
one of the frequent opponents there 709
a giant score I got the Bogle with wider
and have plated a tone with black but
now I got it with wide let's play a
sideline here with 93 angling for the
bishop pal oh yeah hmm I wonder you see
really attacking see for their young
maybe he is III is a bit passive though
but still I I need to take care of the
pawn c6 it's not a very expected move
now he's some kind of can go if form
also lets do a form that looks like a
somewhat inferior version of a semi Slav
for black I have a three extra and he
has early an early commitment down with
them with them with the Queen okay so i
can go push up d3 here not sure Bishop
c3 is probably also good let's start
with that and controlling e5 a little
bit better Bishop d3 maybe have them f5
and then e five
okay maybe just take it and to Bishop e3
setting up simple threats there on the
King side but simple is quite often
effective in chess so don't down don't
need to be too sophisticated often let's
see what to do here yeah I actually
wonder if long castles is an idea or if
this is insane yeah just for g45 trying
to try to blow him out of the water
immediately not sure I mean castles is
certainly good
if i take f6 and play Queenie for isn't
is winning the rook I think it does
window look actually she takes Queen age
six looks quite okay I can he can play
okay I thought like Queenie for Queen at
five maybe wasn't IDM to just lose the
exchange it's just them yeah looks just
a pawn but the whole position looks
dreadful um yeah what now what is the
best way to do it maybe look chewy born
now for Bishop takes a five that look
strong 95 is still had f6 which ya might
might be winning as well but getting in
this tempo is quite quite neat Bishop
takes f5 is a huge threat not just the
pawn but getting the bishop on it on the
h7 square so that's it basically don't
don't really see a move him
if he moves the Queen then num ya
tonight g5 it's just them yeah just a
little bit stronger or end i also have
Queen g5 check repin to the
repositioning the Queen now that that's
just all them yes no mostly I can only
maybe get to some endgame two pawns down
now that would be quite quite a dream
now okay so i will take te keer right
there's nothing nothing wrong with that
and I'm threatening Queen each side
resign edge it made them now that wasn't
that simply was not playable here I
think bb6 seem some seems impossible so
what Teague's and yeah I thought maybe
here he and lock Weiner five but it
ultimately is really just the exchange
there is nothing nothing here in terms
of compensation now that's useless and
gem this is just over rookie one is also
stronger than 95 95 f6 is actually not
that clear because well I can't shake
him but you know this is this is nothing
really sure no like black has very
serious compensation now and it's got a
five in the right moment that he got a
five to make sure before it's not coming
quickly and he's got got fouled so this
is compensation rookie one is much
stronger threatening Bishop f5 and he
has no move here really
Joe I thought maybe I mean something
like this you can continue not to
getting not getting checkmated but check
you just just pawns down for nothing
yeah that I think what was a bit strange
here was the move c6 yeah c6 simply does
not belong into this position if you
play it like like that here with black
you probably should them yeah either up
for see 5 or b 6i guess you can also
play a flexible move let's say rook the
eight and this is also an idea but I
think easiest look so best look
something like be six probably or maybe
c5 maybe c5 like a three take stakes and
now I'm just stay very solid with nie
bede seven or so c6 this is a bit bit
awkward because if you take it white
gets the bishop and it has a direct
threat so it's a bit that's a bit
awkward so back and now White has a nice
choice i can play Bishop d3 or e 4 and
here in this situation it's just a bit
more comfortable for white yam I've got
good a good central advantage and
compared to the semi Slav he has lost
time with Bishop to be formed and then
back to d6 and I have a three for free
which is kind of useful because
sometimes before it's really an option
yeah night here and now it's an
interesting moment here I can I went for
this going for prophylaxis I'm trying to
make sure if I've is not coming um this
is also interesting here directly going
for that but I wasn't sure because of f5
and possibly five maybe Bishop c4 95 is
good thats it's possible the engine
actually say things that bishops III is
a mistake and black gets good play with
c5 this this seems to be wrong maybe
yeah c5 why not that makes sense i was
thinking bishop here something like that
but now be six is probably okay for
like the news f5 is not as some as
weakening as it might look I cannot
attack e6 could claim yeah that's okay
for black so this is probably the real
the real problem like c5 yeah and now it
gets gets really awkward already from
the threatening to meet on h7 so this
has to be done here yeah now he has to
avoid b6 of course something like I
don't know rook the aid or something I
go rook to e1 or bishops e to the
problem really is for black that this is
very easy for y to play I have I can go
before ever like I can go rookie 195
it's just more comfortable for white
okay well thanks for watching